[Music] right now a scenario we would all like
to see is the fall of Putin and the collapse of
his entire regime at the end of the day this is
one of the reasons behind the sanctions program
to turn Russian Elites against the great leader
so we are talking about a campaign of isolation
that goes far beyond trade the goal is to get
to the heart of all Russians for example four
years ago Russia was hosting the World Cup
in the upcoming one in Qatar they are not
even allowed to participate however Putin
himself is also starting to play too much
with the emotions of his people check this out
Putin's call app fuels Russian's anger protests
and violence to give you an idea according
to Forbes more than 700 000 Russians left
the country in just the two weeks following the
announcement of mobilization can we trust these
numbers well the truth is that it's relatively
easy to count them you just need to add up the
figures given by the host countries of course
there might be errors but in theory it seems
reasonable to think that hundreds of thousands of
Russians are fleeing the recruiters we have also
seen all sorts of Street protests and campaigns
on the internet think about it it's one thing
to support a war you see on TV accompanied by
the appropriate propaganda is quite another to
support a war where you are going to be told
to fight on the front lines yourself [Music]
and the truth is that this is not the first time
that this has happened in Russia that's right if
we look at a little bit of History we'll see
that before Ukraine Russia has carried out
two large mobilizations one in World War II and
another one in World War One during World War
II almost all Russians understood that they had
to fight after all they were being invaded by
Germany however the mobilization in World War
one ended really badly for the gremlin in this
case a military Mutiny broke out a mutiny that
was key to the fall of the SARS and the rise
of the Bolsheviks that's correct in today's
video we're going to look at in detail what
happened in Russia in 1917. so the question is
what does the Russia of the tsars and Putin's
Russia have in common could the war in Ukraine
bring about regime collapse like the one that
brought about the Revolutions of 1917. today
on visualpolitik we're going to answer all
of these questions but first obviously
we need to look at some history [Music]
the February Revolution
no I have not made a mistake I did just
say the February Revolution and not the
October Revolution which is the one we all know
about and the fact is that months before the
Communists took control of Russia another
Revolution took place this time a liberal
Revolution so you may be wondering what exactly
happened let's find out the Russian Empire was
going through a period of extreme decadence at
the beginning of the 20th century the reforms
to modernize Russia and bring it closer to
other European powers had been cut short with
the assassination of Tsar Alexander II his
successor Alexander III returned to the old
formula employed by the romanovs for three
centuries a mixture of Orthodoxy autocracy
and nationalism that is the classic idea of
saris Russia based on loyalty to the Romanov
Dynasty government traditional religious
faith and glorification of the motherland
his son Nicholas II did even worse he first
waged a war with Japan that led to one of
Russia's greatest historical humiliations the
discontent provoked the revolution of 1905 in
which the Tsar made some symbolic concessions
such as the creation of the Duma a parliamentary
assembly that when it came down to it lacked real
power but later in 1914 he became the defender
of Serbian nationalism and involved Russia in
the Great War the first world war Russia faced
Germany and the austro-hungarian empire in the
war despite initial victories over the austrians
the Russian army was crushed by Germany causing
thousands of casualties the front was stabilized
and Tsar Nicholas II left for the front to lead
his troops despite the success of the brulasov
offensive based on half a million casualties
Russia was soon cornered again to suffer defeat
after defeat 1917 began in Russia with a very
cold weather and high inflation the majority
of workers in Saint Petersburg or petrograd as it
was known then had to choose between freezing or
trying to keep warm at the risk of starvation
since an egg cost four times as much in 1914
and butter five times as much in addition to food
shortages and extreme poverty 1.7 million Russians
had died in the war another 5 million were
wounded 1.5 million had been taken prisoner
and just as many had deserted from the Army
the protests were continuous and more and more
numerous and no we're not talking about the
Bolshevik Revolution we are talking about the
one that took place months before this was not
a Communist Revolution but a liberal Revolution
in this case the Tsar tried to put down the
Revolt by force but the various garrisons
of Saint Petersburg revolted and disobeyed
the orders received a week later Nicholas II
abdicated sarism was replaced by a provisional
government that was decided to continue Russia's
participation in the Great War while respecting
the international alliances in which Tsar Nicholas
II had involved the country the problem with
this provisional government was that it was
very weak and the streets the petrograd Soviet a
sort of workers and soldiers Council in what was
then the Russian Capital today Saint Petersburg
was becoming more and more powerful while the
most radical revolutionaries the Bolsheviks were
gradually growing stronger in the petrograd Soviet
the Russian provincial government was composed
of liberal politicians moderate socialists and
socio-revolutionaries like Alexander kreninsky
who soon became minister of War and the Navy
at the head of the army karensky played an
All or Nothing Game what did this desperate
attack to avoid defeat in the war consist of
well we're going to look at that right now
the karensky offensive [Music] Russia had
committed itself along with allies to launch
an offensive to divide the attention of the German
and austro-hungarian enemy on two fronts but the
Russian army was not at its best discipline had
fallen sharply after the abdication of the Tsar
the troops didn't trust the commanders because
of the enormous number of casualties suffered by
the Russian army in addition the large number of
casualties had two fundamental consequences for
Russia firstly although the soldiers were still
primarily of peasant origin the latest conscripts
in 1916 had begun to include middle-aged men
secondly and more importantly the new recruits
were being sent to the front with less training
than their predecessors so they were cannon fodder
does this sound familiar at all exactly we're not
going to say that history is repeating itself but
it is clear that there are a number of parallels
Putin's new troops will suffer heavily in Ukraine
as they will have basically no training UK
Intel says in 1917 this lack of preparation
also affected the officers particularly in the
lower ranks the senior officers were aware of
all this and complained about the poor ability of
the new commanders and the poorer quality of the
reinforced received but wait a moment because they
still had to deal with an even greater problem
the new arrivals at the front were opposed to
the war and thought that the failure of the
karensky offensive would sink the provisional
government and would serve to achieve peace
more quickly something similar to what many
Russians in Ukraine might be thinking right
now Russian propaganda has sold the invasion of
Ukraine as a military operation to fight fascism
in the neighboring country Russians therefore
see the intervention in Ukraine as something
completely unrelated to the day-to-day life of
their own country in the earliest 20th century
Russians also did not consider World War one as
an existential issue this is something that the
Russia of the SARS and Putin's Russia have in
common the lack of a clear ideology in running
the country it is clear that ukrainians are
struggling to survive as a country they want
to be independent and have a democratic political
system similar to that of the European Union but
what are the Russians fighting for unlike
the Soviet era today the Kremlin lacks such
a clear ideology as communism in other words
the Soviets wanted to spread their Revolution
to every corner of the planet putinism however
has no such International aspirations Britain's
approach is purely nationalistic it is based
on the idea that there is nothing better in
life than being Russian the old romantic notion
of nationalism already exploited by the tsars
however in the 21st century this is not enough
motivation to compel citizens to go to the front
and even less when you consider the conditions
in which the Kremlin sends its men anger mounts
as Russian draftees thrown into battle without
training equipment the karensky offensive failed
when Russian soldiers mutinied and refused to
continue fighting these insubordinations gave
Germany time to reinforce its front and launch a
counter-offensive far from bolstering the morale
of the Russian army the offensive proved that
the morale of its troops was at rock bottom
and that none of the generals could count on the
soldiers under their command to execute the orders
that they were being given [Music] problems were
piling up for the Russian provisional government
which by then had been pinned down for several
months thanks to the brilliant idea the German
enemy had come up with because someone thought
let's see if Lennon wants to negotiate peace
with us why don't we take him out of his Exile in
Switzerland and bring him to Russia and as we say
here on visualpolitik no sooner said than done in
April of 1917 a crucial historical train journey
took place Vladimir Landon traveled from Zurich
to petrograd he traveled more than three thousand
kilometers on 1864 miles something that would
have been impossible in the midst of the world
war without German help but Berlin's Ambitions
were quickly rewarded upon his arrival in Saint
Petersburg Lennon announced the April Theses
he promised that the Bolshevik came to power
Russia would emerge from the war give the land to
The Peasants and power to the proletariat it was
the era of the historic slogan all power to the
Soviets that's what it is like to have access to
a mass agitator like Lenin he knew perfectly
well what the Russians wanted to hear today
the opposition to Putin does not have a leader a
role model to unite the Russian discontent with
the war and no one seems to be supporting the
Russian opposition at least not with the same
intensity and above all with his many rubles
as the Kaisers Germany placed in the hands of
the Bolsheviks a century ago Edward Bernstein
a German politician who is considered one of
the fathers of social democracy claimed that the
German government financed the Bolsheviks between
1917 and 1918 with about 10 million dollars of
the time to help them take power today Western
support is concentrating on propping up the
Ukrainian government but supporting the Russian
opposition was very effective a century ago so
how did the Bolsheviks seize power check this out
the October Revolution [Music] after the failure
of the offensive the provisional government led
by karensky tried to reorganize the Army
by placing lavar cornelov in charge this
General fed up with the chaos in which Russia was
plunged tried to establish a military dictatorship
to do so he launched a counter-revolutionary
coup d'etat karnalov failed but not because
of the opposition of karenzi's provisional
government which by this team had really no
power over anyone because no one believed in its
Authority cornelov ran up against the Soviets
and fundamentally against the resistance of the
Bolsheviks this field coup reinforced the loss
of authority of the officers in the eyes of the
troops who saw them as mere representatives of
an authoritarian power that had to be ended
it also meant the definitive backing of the
Bolsheviks the most radical revolutionaries
who guaranteed that there would be no return
to sarism the Bolsheviks demanded the government
grant freedom of movement to the Red Guard we are
talking about detachments of workers who were
armed and who would be decisive for the success
of the Revolution the Bolsheviks rallied the
workers and soldiers of petrograd to overthrow
the provisional government a new executive
was formed led by Lenin which took control
of the countryside and created the Checker a
political and Military Intelligence organization
aimed at crushing any dissent what's more as
they had promised they signed a peace treaty
with Germany an agreement that meant an ephemeral
Independence for the Ukrainian Republic [Music]
the Triumph of the October Revolution started
a six-year Civil War the Red Army and the white
Army which comprise all of the enemies of the
Bolshevik Revolution confronted each other
the conflict completely devastated the country
and culminated in the Triumph of Soviet power
possibly today the conditions do not exist for
a revolution to overthrow Putin in other words
who is now the main leader of the anti-putin
opposition Alexi navalny unlike Lennon in his
day Nevada is not an exile but in Russian jail
so it seems to be somewhat difficult to support
him from the West even so navali's allies
continue to move this message was launched
in early October by Ivan's danov navalny's
right-hand man who is currently in Exiles
the problem for revolutions is that things
have changed a lot since Lennon's time the
control over Society over the communications of
dissonance is much greater than it was possible
to have a century ago and another of Putin's
advantages is that he is not so worn out in the
eyes of the Russian population fundamentally
because of the regime's propaganda which does
not try to convince Russians that the world
needs Putin in the same way that for example
chavism extolled Hugo Chavez is very different
Putin's popularity has always rested on the
apathy of the people something similar to what
happened during the tsarist era Russians have
long understood that politics is Putin's in his
friend's business however as the war in Ukraine
is far from going as the Kremlin expected
the discontent is producing movements that
months ago were completely unexpected which
ones let's take a look right now [Music]
put inoffensive
Kremlin has doubled its bet with the partial
mobilization and as you can imagine this does
not come for free as everyone understands except
from Chechen kradov going to the front Lanes
is not any fun in general especially without
adequate preparation what's more by the time
the draft was announced seven months of War
had already passed more than half a year in
which many had seen how their compatriots
returned wounded or even dead so some have
dared to raise their voices against how the
mobilization is being carried out this is
the case of the president of the Republic of
Dagestan the Republic of Dagestan is a Russian
region bordering Georgia and Azerbaijan
on the banks of the Caspian Sea well the
governor of this region is the man you see on
the screen Sergey milkov Sergey milikov is no
Putin Enemy by any stretch of the imagination
he has a high-flying military career he has
risen into a high rank in the National Guard he
is now the highest Authority in this region of
Russia however look at what he has said about
the recruiting officers of the Armed Forces
foreign
that many of those thousands of young
people will not return and leave his
Republic even older but wait a minute because
dissatisfaction with how Russia's partial
mobilization has been organized goes far
beyond an anecdotal problem in Dagestan
it is an established Trend Russia's poorest and
most marginalized regions are the ones that are
risking the most in Ukraine Russia's ethnic
minorities lament the war in Ukraine there
are big unknowns about Russian casualties
because you know that in Wars transparency
is the first casualty but there is research
that clearly indicates that soldiers from
the poorest regions of the Federation such as on
the border with Mongolia and Dagestan itself are
disproportionately represented among Russian
casualties similarly very few young men from
the country's major capitals are dying in
the war undoubtedly a smart move on Putin's
part because maintaining the Loyalty of the
elites will keep him in power Revolutions
in the 20th century spread from the cities to
the periphery and never the other way around
this time there will be no petrograd Soviets but
beware of irritating the peripheral republics so
the question is do you think that at some point
Putin's regime may fall or do you think that his
control over Russian Society is so great that
A revolution is completely impossible you can
leave me your answers in the comments below and
of course don't forget that we have new videos
here on visualpolitik every week so subscribe to
the channel so you don't miss any of our updates
and if you like this video like it so we know
all the best and I'll see you next time [Music]